I grew up in st. Louis Missouri and we
had four seasons we had grass cutting
season we had leaf raking season we had
snow shoveling season we had weed
bullying so my first job was basically
all of those so when I actually got a
real job where I got a paycheck it was
as minimum wage as minimum wage was in
1989 or 90 or whatever was but it was
washing dishes at a restaurant called
Spiros a Greek restaurant run by a man
named Spiro he had dark hair and a big
bushy mustache and was sort of portly
and if he did not like the way you did
something you you heard about it
immediately at a very high volume I was
a big believer in kind of doing jobs so
I was sort of uh close enough was good
enough for me there was a dishwashing
machine which I figured that was kind of
the whole point was that the machine
should do the work and so I was sort of
load didn't load them in very dirty in
them that would come out not as clean as
they could be and that was generally
what I would I would be told exactly how
wash a dish I learned how to actually
not get yelled at by actually doing her
job well I did not get fired I parted
very amicably and and still look back
very fondly at my time in the in the
kitchen
he's a teddy bear he's totally fine he's
not really mad at you I mean he really
is but he doesn't dislike you personally